hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
whenever we talk about history in the
grand sense of things whether it's
formally as historians professionals or
even just informally it's very
convenient to refer to a century right
like what was happening in the 18th
century or the third century or the
fifth century bc or whatever it is but
of course that's a little arbitrary
right i mean it just so happens that
their hundred year spans just so happens
that we picked a starting point they're
not naturally breaking points there all
the time but we still have a feeling
about the 17th century versus the 20th
century for example so the professionals
will sometimes talk about a short
century or a long century when they try
to pinpoint the actual transition
moments where things break up and you
can sensibly talk about themes within
this period of time so today's guest
brad delong is a very well-known
successful economist and someone who
thinks in a very polymathic way about
history science technology economics
politics all those things at once he's
proposing that we think about the long
20th century
that begins in 1870 and ends in 2010.
now he knows that's not a century but he
thinks this is a useful unit of analysis
and he claims that the long 20th century
is the first one in which economics is
the most important way of thinking about
the world well you know he's an
economist what do we expect so that's
going to be one of the questions so
we're going to ask brad why is it
economics but roughly speaking in 1870
he claims a bunch of things happen at
once globalization corporations in the
modern sense also research labs sort of
formalization of scientific and
technological research which really
start to change how the world is
organized and a bunch of things happen
that are kind of chaotic you know
there's world wars there's the great
depression and then maybe you can kind
of see
a battle
shaping up post world war ii
between what you might simplistically
call free market capitalism and social
democracy and in fact to make things a
little more colorful and nuanced brad
focuses on two individual people
friedrich von hayek a champion of free
markets and libertarian economics and
carl pogliani as a representative of
social democrats so brad is not counting
real full-fledged ussr-style communism
as really being a competitor obviously
it was a competitor politically but it
just didn't work very well economically
going into the end of the 20th century
you know what were the options that were
on the table there and the way that he
spells it out there was a moment in the
years days after world war ii when you
might imagine social democracy kind of
winning uh there were heavy taxes on
wealthy people a social welfare net
safety net was being assembled both in
europe and the united states and then it
kind of stopped
being assembled you know it didn't cure
inequality by the way there were still
plenty of problems even in those years
but then there was a shift circa 1980
with reagan and thatcher etc towards
more free markets lower taxes less of a
social safety net
and bread draws the ending point of the
long 20th century at 2010 as sort of the
time when we realized like no this is
just not working right we're we're
beginning to have
financial crises uh things are kind of
breaking down we got to do better than
that people are being burdened by debts
but the interesting frame that he uses
for this is that
things have gotten a lot better in some
very very manifest ways in the 20th
century while at the same time things
were really really terrible in some very
very manifest ways in the 20th century
and he wants to emphasize we can't
ignore either one of those so his new
book that he just come out with a very
long very magisterial book called
slouching toward utopia the idea being
that in some ways you might have
imagined we could realistically aim for
something utopian given the
technological and intellectual advances
of the long 20th century uh and some
people did aim for that but we have
clearly fallen well short why is that
why was utopia possible why did good
things happen about you know median
wealth life expectancy things like that
why did such terrible things happen
there's probably more there than can fit
in an hour-long podcast but at least
we'll give you a little sketch of the
broad scope of things so occasional
reminder for those of you who are fans
of mindscape we have a patreon that you
can join at patreon.com sean m carroll
patreon supporters get ad-free versions
of the podcast as well as the privilege
of asking ask me anything questions once
a month so feel free to join throw in a
dollar per episode or whatever you feel
like doing and whether or not you do
that we love to have you here as members
of the mindscape community so with that
let's go
[Music]
brad delong welcome to the mindscape
podcast it is fabulous to be here um
i've listened to about 30 of the
mindscape podcasts usually while out
with the dogs
and it's been a very good thing for me
to do except at those times when my
situational awareness needs to be
focused on a dog that has found
something too interesting and instead
i'm focused on you and what you're
saying
one of the nicest compliments i was ever
given was that someone said that mine
was the only podcast where they didn't
listen to it at two times speed they had
to listen to it at regular speed so
let's see
something to aim for what was your
favorite episode so far um
oh you would put me on the spot i
confess it was the krebs cycle
yeah i know it was powering biology it
was mclean
um that was really neat and really
absolutely fabulous um absolutely
fabulous to see and i was very happy to
listen to that one good very good anyway
i did not want to put you on the spot
you have you have written a
large impressive book that we need to uh
do injustice to and the first thing i
want to say i don't think i've ever said
this before to a an author on the
podcast but
congratulations for getting the book out
um i was thank you doing a little bit of
preparation for our chat and i came
across a column
in which paul krugman referred to
your already classic though not yet
complete book
yes yes this column was published in
june 2000
yes okay
so you're
that moment then there was there was
only a draft of the first chapter
already because it is back in the 1990s
yeah back in the 1990s i decided that
someone really ought to write an
economic history of the world but one
that started not with you know
[Music]
not with um
pushing pieces of flint against each
other to get sharp edges
or with the industrial revolution
um because
in some degree those really did not
matter that much um
up until 1870 you see um technology
advanced human technology advanced
slowly and we kind of learned and do
more stuff
um the problem was that technology was
advancing slowly
and also that um
in nearly all human societies if you're
a woman
and do a lesser degree if you're a man
too the only way you have any social
power in your old age is if you have
surviving sons
and if population growth is slow which
it must be if technological progress is
slow then about a third of women won't
have surviving suns
and those produce irresistible
malthusian pressures
to keep trying to have kids in the hope
that one of the sons will survive
and until you get over the hump you know
technology advances but population
advances as well
and so you have people with better
technology across the centuries farming
smaller and smaller plots
so that it really looks like the
worldwide standard of living in 1870 was
not that different from what it was in
minus 6 000
much much better technologies on the one
hand
but much much smaller average farm sizes
you know on the other
thus up until 1870 very little changed
from this extremely broad perspective
and yet after 1870 everything has
changed
and that was the important thing to make
to mark out when you write an economic
history of the world well yeah the the
year 1870 we're going to have to get
into i mean you make a very clear
claim that that was the watershed moment
as opposed to other ones that people
have chosen but let me even be more
backgroundy than that and ask about the
decision to
write a history an economic history
right i mean as you are also very clear
about
to
condense over 100 years of human
activity into even a long book is quite
an act of condensation you need a grand
narrative to pretend to pull it together
you know what are the what are the pros
and cons of
trying to
impose a framework even as rewards as it
might be on such a grandiose
set of things
um
they're absolutely totally horrible
right um you know you know what it is to
write a book um
in fact you've written a lot of books
and they're all as best as i can see
very very good books thank you and as
opposed to an article
um which simply has to have a point
and make an argument
and report a result
um and for whom almost all the readers
will be people who you can arrest at the
start by telling them the point or the
result
and then you simply make the argument
and after you know 10 or 15 pages you're
essentially done and then you clean up
afterwards with all the loose ends and
so forth
um
you have a message and you say that
message and boom that's it um
with a book you have to
grab someone's attention and keep it
when it's not clear what the ultimate
end of it will be
you know which means there has to be
something interesting on every page
and then there has to be a reason to
make people turn the page
there has to be a sense of narrative
flow and
you know what happens next
which is in my experience much harder in
non-fiction than fiction at least many
fewer non-fiction writers managed to do
that to be than fiction writers
and then there is perhaps the hardest
thing of all that as people accumulate
these facts and turn the pages forward
they have to feel they're constructing
some kind of web or structure of
knowledge
everything has to make sense things have
to fit together
you know it can't just be eight
different points all of which are clever
which i've put into this book
which by the way i think is the one
thing wrong with will mccaskill's
excellent what we owe the future
which you were talking to someone about
recently
um
so
arresting facts or anecdotes
narrative pull
and then a
grand narrative to guide the structure
which is
going to be false but which you have to
have in order to make the book work
you know it seems to me the difficulty
of the problem goes up at least with the
square of the number of pages
and you're your number of people so yes
it's an
awful lot of work which i think is the
main reason that having written a first
chapter back in 1998 and centered around
saying should i write this
the thing does not come out until 24
years later
well and
one of the
you know
again you're you're very clear about
what it is you're claiming and why it is
interesting and different uh you're not
hiding your assumptions in any way and
you you talk about the long 20th century
so you begin in 1870
you end in 2010 uh you know the the
beginnings ends of the century don't
always line up with historical
developments so that's a fine thing to
do
but i guess the first obvious
substantive question is
if you asked a person on the street
what was the 20th century about
to the extent that it was about anything
i bet a lot of people would say the wars
the world wars the cold war a lot of
people might say
political systems democracy communism
fascism some people might say science
and technology
cars planes yes computers the internet
and you're making the substantive claim
no it's actually about economics
well
science and technology play an infinite
amount have an infinite amount to do
with it
um
but you know i'm
looking back at the years say since
minus six thousand
and i'm looking back at the fact that
the standard of living of say thomas
jefferson's slaves in 1800 does not look
that much different than the standard of
living of marcus tulia cicero's slaves
in the year minus 50. um
and i'm constructing an extremely crude
index of human technological competence
over the top ages
in which it's just i take what we think
average living standards were at any
point at the time worldwide and we
multiply that by the square root of
population
and that gives us a nice index of our
ability collectively to manipulate
nature and to organize ourselves
productively
and you look at those three things and
1870 stands out like a sore thumb
as what you would call a phase
transition
the point where things change and where
whatever history was beforehand it looks
very different afterwards
but sort of systematically i could
imagine uh
attributing that change purely to
science and technology or purely to
political
progress or degradation but is it an
economic systems change or an economic
attitude or is it just that you don't
have to say it's all we have to say it's
all of those it's all right okay that
you have to have a certain sense of
scale
um enough people talking to each other
so that people with different ideas can
communicate and effectively bounce
um them off of each other and enough of
a system of memory you need to have a
habit of empirical investigation and a
way of keeping track of things
and almost surely
the assigning of ruthless priority to
successful experiment
right as opposed to saying that the
ideas we're going to claim as true or
think about are those that make us happy
with our current social order and cement
it say
um that the move to experiment is
absolutely massive and important
um you need to have
you know say
you almost surely need to have a market
economy of some sort because
that's pretty much the only way to crowd
source
the problem of figuring out what to
produce and how to produce it better
that is try anything other than a market
economy and decision making is
concentrated somewhere and it's
concentrated somewhere where the
knowledge probably isn't
and you also are not turning every
single human brain to thinking my life
could be better if i could figure out a
better way to do this
but all of this up until 1870 or so you
know um
all of this gets you is a rate of
technological progress of less than half
a percent per year yep rising
substantially over time you know it's
not half a percent per year before 1500
you know it's more like 1 20th of a
percent per year and that it accelerates
but um
even if your technologies are getting
better at half a percent per year
um that kind of gets neutralized if
population is growing uh you know one
percent per year
you know and we know that a
pre-industrial no artificial birth
control human population that's not
nutritionally stressed
that such a thing quadruples in a
century
right it grows at maybe
1.4 1.5 per year
um
half a percent per year of technological
progress
is not enough to get from out from under
the hammer of patriarchy and the
requirement that you have surviving sons
in order not to be burned as a witch in
your old age
um and so you're kind of trapped in this
year in this malthusian trap you know
even up to 1870 even with all the
wonderful things of automatic textile
machinery and steam engines and coal and
you know better metallurgy and so forth
it's in 1870 that things switch that
technological progress more than
quadruples again
um
that you get technology growth rates of
2.1 per year more or less constantly
from 1870 to 2010
as opposed to less than half
um and i think this happens because we
finally get the last pieces of the
institutional configuration to fall into
place
you know the industrial research lab to
rationalize and routinize
discovery and development
the modern corporation to rationalize
and routinelize development and
deployment
and then the fully global market economy
to make it extremely profitable to
deploy but then also to give everyone
else a chance to look at you
and figure out how to copy what you've
done and so diffuse
the science and technology that are at
the core of it
you know all over the world so that
today we have a world massively richer
than anyone before
so it's those three things just to
repeat just to drive it home since this
is so important to the argument three
things roughly coincided circa 1870 the
yeah corporation the industrial research
lab globalization what is there
just saying those things out loud makes
me want to ask
why did they suddenly coalesce around
1870 were there some underlying things
or is just they finally percolated up so
you're not giving credit to
the enlightenment the scientific
revolution the industrial revolution
there's some credit there's some credit
there those yeah those are all mature
around 18 cents
there yeah
but at least you can argue that those
just give you steampunk world right
right those still give you a world in
which population is growing at maybe one
percent per year or less and
technology's advancing
but you know better technology but
smaller farm sizes with a growing
population
um and it's very hard to get
agricultural productivity up
you know that in the industrial
revolution century you are sending
people thousand 000 miles away
in or with pickaxes in order to knock
bird [ __ ] off of rocks
in the south atlantic and then move it
back to england so you can't have farm
enough you can add enough nitrogen to
get the far keep the farms going to keep
the population from starving um
you know the steampunk world's not a
terribly attractive one it's one in
which many most people are still at dire
poverty at what the world bank says as
three dollars a day or less you know and
you know that's the world we're in even
with the royal society and trust nothing
but experiment and the enlightenment
and marvelous machines and so forth um
why in 1870 well you know there's
there is a great discontinuity in
getting the telegraph and as important
the submarine telegraph which is a
really really hard technological problem
to solve
and
also the screw propellered iron holds
steamship you know
things that mean that it's a lot cheaper
to ship wheat
by railroad from north dakota to new
york and then by steamship from north
dakota to hamburg
than it is to carry rye from you know
swamps and east prussia to the local
right
to the local river and then down the
river on the barge and then so forth um
that
all of a sudden getting your staple
commodities from anywhere in the world
is a real important thing that you one
might analogize to a phase change and
that just kind of happens from
cumulative technological advance
you know
the industrial research lab and the
corporation um
a lot of the corporation is owed to the
u.s civil war
right and finally having to figure out
how to assemble a 2.1 million army and
send it um some place
and
you know as for the industrial research
lab well
rationalizing and routinizing things um
very hard to know where it came from um
quite possible we would not have gotten
it but you know before the industrial
research lab if you're an inventor you
also have to do everything else
right scientist engineer machinist
technician financier empresario
and so it's very very difficult to get
crazy people who are very good
at science and invention to be able to
specialize um
you know my favorite example is nikola
tesla
who
genuinely could make electromagnetic
fields get up and dance
in his day in a way that um
i mean you can say it was all in
maxwell's equations
right um in fact you can say that all of
special relativity is in maxwell's
equation so nobody noticed it for 50
years
um but
no one understood
how crazy the idea of say long distance
distributing alternating current
power could possibly be
until tesla and
he pushed that through but the only way
he pushed that through was because
george westinghouse found him
and surrounded him with an industrial
research lab because otherwise he was
totally socially inept and incapable of
carrying through on anything um
you know and it is absolutely great it
is absolutely crazy i'm going to
transfer energy from one place to
another not by sending electrons with
energy but by just shaking them 60 times
a second
yes no i i struggled with it myself as a
youth but uh but so in some sense it's
an efficiency revolution rather than
some particular big idea like we had all
these little ideas about science and
technology and so forth but
globalization and research and corporate
organization helped us
take advantage of them and therefore
increase the rate of economic growth
and massively increase the scale right
you know critical mass is the other good
analogy perhaps
that instead of someone inventing
something and that invention then kind
of diffusing and being perfected or at
least improved
is starting with 1870 and indeed it's
called the second industrial revolution
and indeed robert gordon wrote a
wonderful book about it
it's kind of boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom in sector after sector
technology after technology thing after
thing
um
and then i could have written a lot of
books with 1870.
you know i could have concentrated on
science and technology i could have
concentrated on technology and corporate
form
i could have concentrated
on your corporate forms and industrial
structure and industrial succession i
could have concentrated on how
wealth and mass literacy and mass
communication led to people like yo karl
popper and so forth hoping for an open
society
um
i wound up concentrating on political
economy
that is if technology's advancing so far
that your entire economy is
revolutionized every single generation
and thus all of the society and politics
and culture built on top of that found
their foundations totally different
after one generation than they were
before
and people have to try to rebuild social
and economic institutions so that they
can kind of cooperate and govern
themselves on the fly
um
that's a hell of a ride that's a very
difficult process that has many things
both wonderful and terrible happening
and so i wound up
having to pick one thing having to pick
one grand narrative choosing the
political economy one
not so much the details of how this
enormous pace of technological advance
happened but with it happening in the
background how did human societies and
polities react right and how did we
manage to both become rich and also kill
a hundred million of our felons this is
of course good question
and
i do want to get to the 20th century but
the other thing i think to emphasize
that you do very effectively is
how poor we were before 1870 uh not just
for the average income but especially
you correctly emphasize child mortality
and uh you know the danger of just
giving birth it was it was a different
world before 1870 yes
oh yeah like you know british queens of
england between william the conqueror
and queen victoria
kind of by my count one in seven of the
queens of england die in childbirth
and you know these are the most cossated
women in the in all of southern england
you know being female is not for sissies
um back in the before modern medicine
modern technology
um
and we can argue about whether that's
because
as a species we're really really clutchy
as far as childbirth or lots of reasons
connected with our big brainness and
other things or whether we can argue
that it's just that you know after you
invent agriculture that agrarian
societies are really horrible places
right
that average adult male height dropping
from five foot eight to five foot three
or so when we move from being hunter
gatherers to
farmers you know our teeth getting
infinitely worse enormous additional you
know i mean
plus the fact that a a population that
ought to be growing at you know one and
a half percent per year under
pre-industrial conditions if you're not
nutritionally stressed
is instead growing before 1500 at only
20th a percent per year um and it's not
because other animals are eating us
except for the microorganisms the micro
parasites um
it's because um
it's because we have we are either
imposing enormous social pressure on
people to delay the age of marriage well
into the late 20s which is happening in
some societies
or it's because our population has grown
and our farm sizes relative technology
are so small
um
that
women are so malnourished that ovulation
is becoming hit or miss and children are
so malnourished that their immune
systems are highly compromised and
they're being carried off by the common
cold
right
that the world in which a woman has to
have you um
you know eight pregnancies for six live
births for three children to survive to
the age of six
and then for two to actually reproduce
and even then one third of women are
left without surviving sons
you know watching that many of your
babies die and watching them be that
hungry
you know that they're five foot three
rather than five foot eight at their
adult height that has to be a life with
enormous amounts
of misery and unhappiness that you wish
you could avoid and built into it at its
core
good so uh
agrarian societies were bad and
not only bad compared to what came after
them but also compared to what came
before in many ways which is which is
fascinating to me it's a self-imposed
kind of
suffering in any way yeah
i mean you do see
certainly skeletons we dig up before the
agricultural revolution are bigger and a
lot buffer yeah than the skeletons of
your typical peasant or your typical
agrarian age person unless there's
someone extremely lucky like the
inhabitants of san francisco bay who
found that little to eat other than
shellfish
or say the comanche or the sioux after
the horse escapes from the spaniards who
can actually
have a strong technological advantage as
they hunt and gather the buffalo and
also apparently hunter-gatherers have a
lot more leisure time than agrarian uh
workers do
they do although there is the question
of
there's the question of what leisure
time for an animal really is surely
that is i have two dogs
they love to run about
um they sleep a lot
we're trying to compete the labrador
retriever from blowing up to become a
spherical dog of radius r
which means she doesn't get to eat
nearly as much as she would want to
um
and so clearly the ener the energy
budget constrains them
um in a bunch of ways you know that lots
of their daily sleeping time is not
really leisure but is recovering from
kind of
trying to figure out how to climb a tree
to eat a squirrel which the older one is
still trying to do
right i mean he's seen squirrels can fly
increase why can't i optimism that's
great
good question
we're different right that
if you think of people or animals that
are in some sense near the edge of their
energy budget
um a lot of the leisure is downtime um
but you know we have these big brains
yeah
and yes they're enormously energy
intensive
um but still at least some of the time
they keep functioning during what is
what you would think of as
biomedical
low
energy expenditure downtime
and we think about lots and lots of
things
except unless of course when we've
simply exhausted ourselves and are too
tired to think productive
so i think it sounds like there's a
whole nother book here but i do want to
i do want to get to the 20th century
there are many other books here there
are many ones yes so in 1870 uh we some
things happen things come together this
is often a feature of phase transitions
that they actually happen sometime after
the initial wheels were put into motion
and of course there's going to be a lot
of people who immediately say look
sure
economic growth and technological
innovations skyrocket they finally
outpace population growth but what we
get in the 20th century is
hundreds of millions of murders and
deaths and we also get vast inequality
so i mean you have a we do we'll get
into the nuances we might do but what is
your grand narrative of the 20th century
i mean look you go and look at um
this book tomasello um
spoke the city of the sun or francis
bacon's
work around 1600 for the first time
people are saying hey wow wait a minute
we have better technology now clearly
and visibly than we had a century ago
um a thing that people hadn't noticed
beforehand because it hadn't really been
true
and you know francis bacon talks about
enlarging the human empire for the
affecting of all things possible
um and people begin to think maybe
they'll be
a good technology in which we are
much more capable of doing things as a
species in the future
and people then turn around and reflect
on that and you know the dominant
reflection that goes back into aristotle
is that um
you know in a poor society
everybody can't have enough
and if you and your family are going to
have enough given how low average
productivity is
the way you're going to do that is to
become part of an elite
um that actually lives well by taking a
lot of stuff away from others by an
exploitation and domination machine
you know you have thugs with spears you
have their tame accountants
their tame propagandists their tame
bureaucrat
um the propaganda explain why all of
this is actually the way things have to
be and is good
um
the accountants and the bureau keep
track of where the stuff is and make
sure you get your large share um the
bureaucrats um
issue commands and say we'll send the
thugs with spears after you if you don't
organize things it does seem familiar
and then most of his most of history is
you know because it's written by the
people who can write
is written by the propagandists the
bureaucrats and the accountants and
presumes
that not only is humanity poor but
there's this exploitation and domination
machine um going on um which means that
even the elites spend a lot of time
exploiting and dominating each other
because that's what they're used to
and you know after 1870 the prospect is
we can bake a large enough economic pie
so that everyone can really have enough
you know no longer have to see half
their babies die no longer spend much of
their time worrying about how hungry
they are or how cold or how wet they are
and you know given that all the
requirement that you have this vicious
exploitation and domination machine is
going away
you know that the story of vladimir
lenin in in 1916 in zurich being asked
you know how is it that communism could
possibly work wouldn't people just grab
all the stuff
and looking at his lunch partner and
saying i notice you haven't grabbed the
sugar bowl
put it in your coat and run off with it
yet um
from the perspective of 1870 or
before kind of once you solve the
problem of baking a big enough pie
you're the problem of slicing it
equitably so that people have enough or
at least so that you know inequality
doesn't bind that tightly and then the
problem of utilizing it to live lives in
which people are kind of happy healthy
secure and safe
those would seem to be smaller second
order problems because our marvelous
technologies would have solved the first
order
um
and yet those problems the problems of
slicing and tasting have plummet stuff
since 1870
we manifestly do not live in a utopia
um
we as a species that is you know um when
i look around at the life of a tenured
professor at a
research university where i don't have
four teaching preparations a semester
for eight classes a year it looks pretty
damned utopian to me um
that with the exception of people like
us we are manifestly not in anything
like
a utopia and so one big question is why
have we done such a bad job at
collectively solving the problems of
slicing and tasting
um when with our scientists and
engineers and then with our engineers
and you know
corporations and then with our abilities
to organize in our technicians
we have done such an absolutely
marvelous job at solving the problem of
producing enough
so that now you look at the depths of
the production process of a lot of
things around us
and you know it is very hard to believe
that people have been s that that jumped
up east african planes aids with many
problems with their mental heuristics
have been able to actually make say um
the m1 apple silicon microprocessor that
apple designed and that tsmc has managed
to manufacture
can actually be something done by humans
um
to make stone carry electronic charges
in such a way that they process
information at such a scale is something
i still cannot believe this has been
created by a bunch of jumped up monkeys
so to vastly oversimplify if i can put
it this way the scientific revolution
industrial revolution the enlightenment
maybe
let us conceive of utopia in a way that
we couldn't before the efficiency
revolution circa 1870 made it plausibly
attainable
and the world's historical question is
how come we've done such a bad job but
actually making it happen yes yes yes
now it's not a
horribly bad job right average income
per capita in the world today is
something like thirteen thousand dollars
a year
well there was
maybe
twelve hundred dollars a year back in
1870 and maybe nine hundred dollars a
year back in 1500
and there's also the question of um
you know that is
measures of income per capita are kind
of measures of how much things cost
but what we'd really like would be
measures of how much things are worth to
people you know adding consumer surplus
on top of factor cost
and certainly when i look at my life
there are an awful lot of goods mostly
related to information and knowledge and
entertainment
in which there seems to be an enormous
wedge between how much it's worth to me
and how much it costs
um
like you know i'm
like you you know when i read one of
your books
um you know i maybe pay 12 for it on
the kindle of which you get one dollar
and 20 cents yep and yet you know i
spend maybe three or four hours um
interacting with it um which means in
some sense i read words and then i argue
with you
or at least i spin up a subterring
instantiation of what i imagine your
mind to be
from the black marks on the page run it
and the wet wear and then in a kind of
schizophrenic
converse and argue and say this is wrong
and so forth um
and those four hours are worth an awful
lot more to me than even a dollar twenty
or twelve dollars you know um
i'd willingly pay one hundred or two
hundred dollars for the experience
and yet this enters the gdp accounts
with only twelve dollars
um of value or
and
vastly more than the factor cost and
vastly more than the 1.20 um sense that
you actually get
so from one perspective i am in a
parasocial relationship with you in
which i'm an enormous beneficiary and
owe you enormous amounts of stuff
in some indo-european gift exchange
[Laughter]
there's that question
and you know the techno utopians say our
gdp statistics are flawed because of the
shift to information and entertainment
goods and they may well be right
but even if we don't take account of
that even if we just say what are things
worth in terms of how much they cost
you know average living standards 15
times what they were in the battle
agrarian age where your boys grew up to
be five foot three and you were hungry a
lot of the time
that's a huge accomplishment
um
that's a wonderful thing
it is a horror and a scandal that we
still have 500 million people living at
a pre-industrial standard of living in
such a rich world
but it ain't utopia
it's not and for
grand narrative purposes in part uh you
set up the battle for the soul of the
20th century as one between
friedrich von hayek and carl pauliani uh
polanyi whose name i can never get right
and
some people and that's weird that's the
you know you're that's a little
provocative right there like people
might be thinking well shouldn't it be
like karl marx and keynes or adam smith
or something like that but you have your
reasons and
polany in particular is is less
well-known on the street probably than
even hayek is so
what's your brief intro
exactly
he's even less well known to me than his
brother michael
oh yeah oh his brother michael
and many i actually played with doing
michael rather than friedrich von hayek
because you know michael palani with his
mercenary and fiduciary institutions and
sources of science and so on and so
forth
is i think a broader and much deeper
thinker than hayek who is just
one piece of palami who is the kind of
the mercenary institutions the advantage
of the market economy as a crowdsourcing
mechanism of a particular way
dedicated at creating value as opposed
to michael who is that but is also
saying oh and by the way we have this
very different institution called
science
with its extraordinary ruthless and
incredibly cruel assignment of priority
which is a fiduciary institution that
produces enormous amounts of knowledge
and so have it be a battle of the
brothers
that would have been good between
michael palani saying we need science as
a fiduciary institution to generate the
knowledge
we need the market economy in order to
crowdsource the problems of turning this
knowledge to productivity
and then we have a good society
and then his older brother carl palani
saying wait wait wait
if you have a market economy
what that means is that your only source
of
social power or influence your only way
to get
things accomplished that you want
accomplished is if you have will
you know that the only rights that the
market economy recognizes our property
rights and the only property rights that
are worth anything are those that help
in making whatever the rich have a
serious jones to have
and carl pallani says that can't be a
society people cannot stand for that
people do not stand for the idea that
only those who are lucky enough to be
wealthy in any generation that they're
the only people
who have any influence or power or
authority and that everyone else has to
bow and scrape and desperately hope for
crops and it's that it's that yeah but
michael palani is even
less well known in the social sciences
than
yeah so and hayek is uh
a pretty well-known guy in the social
sciences has his acolytes and i think
he's a good foil as
kind of the apotheosis of free-market
classical liberalism slash capitalism
right so and you you do you criticize
i mean
except in his old age where he gets
really cranky and semi-fascist you know
um
the problem is that we need the market
economy and thus the priority of
property rights
in order to get out of the traps of
over-bureaucratization and central
planning and actually get a world in
which everyone can have freedom to try
to do things for themselves that they
like
and with market incentives that means
everyone has a powerful incentive to
figure out how to be more productive and
thus make things better for all
um it's a marvelous way of turning and
not just the one human brain of the
director of planning but everyone's
brain
to figuring out how can we become a more
productive and better society
the problem hayek says is that this is
unjust and unfair
you know that in a market economy you
have social power and influence only if
you're rich which means you had to have
control of
the right resources at the right time in
the right place sorry you said hayek
that the problem hayek said was that
yeah yeah yeah and hayek said well gee
this is a problem the market economy
will produce wealth um and thus
abundance but it will not produce social
justice
and so the right answer is to throw
social justice over the side it's a
mirage
we do not dare ask for it
because if we ask for society to produce
not just the abundance and wealth that a
market economy can produce
but if we ask it to produce social
justice as well we'll wind up destroying
its ability to produce wealth and we'll
be on the road to serfdom
and and what years and years that's
that's kayak what year um saying it's
not great but it's the best we can do
when is he saying this
i would say the
1940s and 1950s okay you know he's
saying we understand the attraction of
social justice
um but it's a it's a temptation we must
resist
you know the places in the road to
serfdom where he
credits and praises his british labour
party intellectual adversaries
saying you know your brave people your
benevolent people you're kind of bold
people you want only the best for
humanity but it's just not going to work
we have to retreat to the market
yeah i mean by this time in the 40s and
50s sort of the battle lines have
already been pretty clearly drawn
between capitalism and socialism right
and he's arguing that i mean to greatly
oversimplify
um
whatever
you know let's say let's take inequality
as one of the purported eagles of
capitalism and hayek wants to say well
you think you're going to
battle inequality by having some
centralized government control or levers
but that's going to lead you right to
authoritarianism yeah there's no other
choice
yep
and
you contrast this with polany who wants
to say
the unfettered market is just a little
bit inhuman he really is emphasizing the
the human side of things in a nice way
yes
yes well that young carl
you know carl pallani is one of these
people who's
whose workers ideas are great
but you know his ability to express them
is rather lousy
plenty of those yeah right um
last monday i was having coffee with a
professor friend who read my book and
said you know after i read my your book
i felt i had to go and finally read
bolani
horrible horrible
absolutely horrible
you know
it's
i don't know if this is people who are
were originally raised in german writing
in english or if it's something else but
you know it's some
well
certainly a bunch of people are badly
translated from the german of whom i
think maxine lovesio's dax baber is the
most primary but people whose ideas are
great but their books are almost
inapproachable
um hyman minsky was another such right
that practically everyone who knows
about hyman minsky is actually reading
charlie kindleberger's the version of
hyman minsky who kindergarten takes
minsky's framework and uses it to tell
lots of stories about mania's panics
crashes financial
for fraud financial crises and so forth
um
i mean i would say that solani's central
point is yes you know the market
is immensely powerful and productive
um but
it's not good for humans that the only
source of social power in a society be
that the rich are the only people whose
words count
and furthermore people simply will not
stand for this
you know they will revolt
in one way or another um
that you know people insist that they
have a right
to the kind of life
that they expect that they were going to
live into a certain amount of stability
in their community and in the build
environment around them
um people insist that they have a right
the level of income which they kind of
deserve given how hard they work
and given how hard they trained in order
to it and people
believe that they have a right to
stability right that their job be there
or if one job ends another one show up
for
and the idea that all three of these
things right that the fabric of
your life and your environment your
level of income of command over
resources
and indeed the stability that you know
where your 2 000 calories plus essential
nutrients are going to come from next
year or even next week
that all of these are at risk and at
hazard
depending on whether
the system that you're embedded in
passes some maximum profitability test
made by some 30 year old rootless
cosmopolitan 5 000 miles away who's
never seen you right you know people
simply will not stand for this um
and it becomes really really important
when technology is revolutionizing the
economy every generation
and thus requiring that things change
and things change massively simply
because the old ways do not work
so the imperatives of the market economy
try to reduce everything to property
rights
and then try to reorganize everything so
as to make the property rights as
valuable as possible and that is the
application of science and technology to
production and that makes us rich
but everyone around says
wtf exclamation point
this is not what we ordered yo and
people react
and they can react smartly and dumbly
um they can establish welfare states or
they can assemble in large crowds in
nuremberg and acclaim the fuhrer
they can wage wars they can establish
gulags they can shoot people and send
them to concentration camps they will
react um and so you will have this dual
fight
during which
the market economy attempts to abolish
you know society understood as other
sources of social power and influence
and voice other than property
and society will respond it will
counter by trying to curb the market and
also trying to achieve what it thinks of
as social justice
um in which other forms of social power
are validated and in which people kind
of get what they deserve
in any society's view of social justice
it may well not be a very just thing
you'd consider all the people who voted
for
you know donald trump
um
because they thought that he would
properly deal with minorities who had
all been
gotten things more than they deserved
under obama because of the free obama
phone program
[Music]
but you have heartbreaking stories of
you know
hispanic factory workers in
kansas whose
education and training programs are
being cut
by
and don't understand why trump is
attacking them yeah
rather than attacking the many other
people who um
as mitt romney said in the
2012 election were always going to vote
for the democrats because the democrats
gave them free stuff that they didn't
deserve
and he was never going to convince such
people to take responsibility for their
lives yeah
so the i mean the main
dividing line i think that you want to
talk about and work through in the book
it's it's not communism versus
capitalism right i mean there was for
much of the 20th century a cold war and
there was this
whole part of the world that purported
to be communist and we can argue whether
it was or not but
uh there's the
sub debate within the western world
about more or less free market
capitalism versus social democracy right
and is it fair to sort of associate
polany with the social democracy side of
that
or i'd say social democracy heading over
into socialism yeah okay
um
that
you know um
social democracy is very much we should
have a market economy
but we should also have um a lot of
publicly provided stuff
right of stuff that's simply not part of
the market you know everything from
parks to in civilized countries
healthcare that we simply take out of
the market you know education
um
or at least primary and secondary
education those really
are things we should provide for
everyone by virtue of their status as
citizens and residents rather than
requiring that people pay for them a
whole bunch of public provision
and then a whole bunch of income
redistribution as well
you know
progressive taxes and
kind of benefits provided to good people
and cash benefits
so that even the poor have some social
power to get things done
um
and
you know polany would say and in fact
did say that you know yes um this is a
good system you know is it sustainable
no that people have a very strong sense
that the kinds of social power people
should exercise
are those that are appropriate to what
they deserve and what their role is
and there seems to be a very strong
thing that too much income
redistribution is in some sense unfair
that back when i worked for the clinton
administration we found ourselves always
saying that our social insurance
programs were for hard-working american
families
as opposed to citizenly citizen
entitlement
that somehow saying that people should
have things should have
a good life because they were citizens
or at least have social power to
accomplish things you'd dress up like
spock at comic-con even if they weren't
working hard
that
offended people enormously politically
incorrect yeah
yeah although it was strange right that
um that kind of i've gotten about um
thirty thousand dollars a year extra
since birth on average
um you know because my grandfather was
very smart and very lucky
and employed a bunch of engineers who
did a bunch of very good things
including figuring out how to
desulphurize natural gas
which is not only very valuable in terms
of allowing you to use natural gas
without stinking up the place
but you know also
four carbon hydrogen bonds in a methane
molecule right and only two in a
hydrocarbon chain
um that as far as global warming is
concerned natural gas is only half the
damage
of the longer stuff
um
and so
he became the richest man between tampa
and orlando for a while as a result of
this and i've gotten about thirty
thousand dollars a year of resources for
me and my family from that
very few people
are as offended
by that
um or at least very few people on the
center and the right are as offended by
that
my left-wing friends are truly totally
as are offended by one relatively poor
guy in wichita actually getting a cell
phone they didn't pay for because george
w bush
pushed through this program right um
about how we ought to democratize cell
phone access as these as the pay phones
are vanishing
and
right-wing nut jobs then decided to call
these things obama phones
um
and that's an interesting right that's
an interesting thing about societal
perceptions of social justice
but i've gotten ourselves off on a
tangent you have that's okay but the
main point was that the main point was
that social democracy a combination of a
market economy public provision
and then a whole bunch of entitlements
even means-tested entitlements for
people as citizens
that seemed to fail its sustainability
test in the global north at least in the
1970s
you know and you get the rise of reagan
and thatcher and the shift to
a different and um
some more fraught way of thinking how we
should organize society which historian
gary gerson calls the neoliberal order
right with which we're still grappling
and which is
just even if social democracy failed to
satisfy people's beliefs about what a
utopia should be like
neoliberalism seems to satisfy people's
beliefs even less well
let's give the
as you say there was a
reaction against the
maybe feeling that social democracy was
effective in winning in the decades
after world war ii um
in the 70s and 80s
and and hayek was one of the people who
kept getting referred to um
there is an argument to be made there
even if we disagree with it there was an
argument you talk about ronald kos
in uh your book and how he would argue
that
even if you think something unfair is
happening it's just because the market
isn't as
uh leaned into as it should be like if
you really let the market do everything
then any unfairness can be purchased and
that's good yeah
yes yes yes yes so in part i want to say
that that's that
is in some sense this is a university of
chicago it electrical moves yeah but
even where it looks like the market is
failing it's actually succeeding if you
look deeply enough at it
and this is counter posed to the
berkeley intellectual move
that even if you think the market is
succeeding if you look deeply at enough
it's failing in some
more subtle way
um
and why does that i mean i think that
that's obviously wrong and in part
because you know
of both computational and
communicational and power exertion
inefficiencies in human beings like you
know the
it's just easier to abuse individual
poor people than it is to have a
completely efficient market right is
that your favorite explanation for why
that fails or do you have a different
one
that's a very good one right that is
that you see this i think most in
finance right that is
kind of it's very easy to explain
why um
say i and the people at phil's coffee
half a miles away are in a mutually
productive gift exchange relationship
that makes both of us
um much better off
that is they have good coffee
i have money which is generalized social
power that can do with good things right
you do things
um
the marginal value of my money or at
least the last digit is a lot less than
my marginal value of a good cup of
coffee early in the morning i benefit
enormously from being able to go down to
phil's and get them to
give me some coffee in exchange for
money
and in return
they have coffee they have huge amounts
of coffee you know if they were to take
the coffee that they have and um
actually try to drink it in a day
their livers could not cope and they
would die
um
so we have a clear win-win exchange
where i'm exchanging money for something
i find extremely useful
um or am at least addicted to
because people like michael pollan would
say i really should live without this
power
it's a nerve poison for bugs after all
why are you drinking it
um
the problem is when you go into finance
what you're doing is
it's money now versus money later
it's money in this state of the world
being as opposed to money in that state
of the world
um it's maybe we rearrange these money
flows a bit because that way we better
align our incentives to be careful
but it's not that we're training good
trading good for good or money for good
it's we're trading money for money
and so whatever
whatever actual value created there
you know me valuing money later more and
money now less and then valuing money
now more and money later less
those are very very thin
which means that there are in general
two ways to make money in finance one of
which
is to actually find one of these margins
where there is a win-win exchange
because the money at different times and
states of the world is actually worth
different amounts to different people
and the other is to find someone who
doesn't understand the risks you're
asking them to bear
and load the risks off on it
and you know we see this in finance over
and over and over again
which is one thing that makes it so
enormously attention-graphic
we're seeing this right now with kind of
the great crypto meltdown
it's lots of places where the market is
manifestly working enormously horribly
and lots of people are taking on risks
they do not understand and getting
cheated out of enormous amounts of
social power
and lots of people who actually are
somewhat malevolent psychopaths
or at least grifters who have managed to
convince themselves that they're not
grifters who have run a grift not just
on their customers but on themselves
um are winding up with fabulous amounts
of social power that they then can
use to control things off into the
future
and you know the
the great crypto boom in meltdown is not
anyone's idea of what anything like a
utopia should look like
and you know you can say that this is
you know the
the complete efflorescence of how a
market economy is actually not that good
in aligning our collective actions with
what the good society would achieve
but then once you admit that you then
have to kind of generalize and move on
down and saying how important and
powerful are the market failures and all
the other parts of the economy as well
and so the hard position that you know
the market giveth the market taketh away
blessed be the name of the market um
hayek would say that we kind of have to
go there because bureaucracy is our
worst
because market and bureaucracy are the
only things we really know how to do
and
as long as we can say the market giveth
the market taketh away blessed be the
name of the market
we avoid the temptation to reach for
social justice via bureaucracy which is
in the end going to send us on the road
to serfdom
so it's in some sense a noble lie in
platonic it's not something we believe
that's true but it's something we need
to believe to have as good a society as
we can
why did you pick 2010 as the end of the
long 20th century what happened then
that was equivalent to 1870
he had a huge argument about this
you know um
that you know i'm
you know one possibility was to say that
a key part of the
kind of
thing was not just
um
corporation research lab and
globalization but you know american
exceptional the united states says what
leon trotsky called the furnace where
the future was being forged
um the place that was kind of leading
the world into the future and hoping to
find the road to utopia in the 20th
century
and that kind of came to an end in 2003
when you know george w bush threw over
the united nations project at even the
nato project
and said that the united states is not
the benevolent hegemon um trying to
guide the world into a peaceful future
but that we're going to assemble the
pieces of
a coalition of the willing
and in the words of one bush
administration official pick up some
shitty country and throw it against the
wall
well
so you can say that kind of that
dropping away of american exceptionalism
there's a piece of it
you could date it to 2006
when the numbers start going bad on the
information technology revolution
and it looks not like a continuation of
the 02 per year growth but instead
technology growth in the global north at
least appears to have half at least
according to our conventional
measurement says
intel stopped talking and as
some people say the
neoliberal dismantling of the great
corporate research laboratories
in the interests of pursuing short-term
profits
you know did a huge number on all of
your colleagues in the applied physics i
know that one applied chemistry yes you
know there
what was supposed to be a huge number of
effectively 10-year track jobs in
all kinds of research labs kind of
vanished and so all of a sudden getting
jobs like yours became a lot lot harder
so that you know the best physicists i
know after assistant professorships and
so that wellesley and princeton
wind up going either into finance or
into um
game design for wizards of the coast
and so forth
which you know is are wonderful things
to do or can be wonderful things to do
but you really do not need
phd
in order to do it
it is it's a potential
example of a market failure yeah
yeah
we could call it 2007 when it became
very clear that alan greenspan's bet
that the federal reserve could kind of
handle any financial weirdness that
emerged and that we did need more
experimentation in financial
vehicles because the old ones weren't
doing that great a job turned out to be
a huge mistake
it could be 2010
when the world decided that you know um
that in some sense the keynesian idea
that you prioritize full employment um
whenever something goes wrong with the
economy that that was massively rejected
by a bunch of people largely for i think
the ideological reason that they had
convinced themselves that you know once
you allow that keynes is right
then you really can't believe that the
market distribution of wealth is a good
thing um and so we had this lost half
decade from 2010 to 2015
when at least the great and good were
very happy because stock prices were
high and inflation was low
never mind the fact that unemployment
was high and no real person dare to ask
for a raise
um
or could you say
2016 when all of this came due with the
rise of what um
people tend to call populism but which
madeleine albright called a renewed
fascism you know and who am i to argue
with her
managed to actually win a presidential
election in the united states of america
um
uh in the end 2012 i rejected 2016
because
i'd see donald trump as a symptom rather
than a cause
[Music]
it would be say the popping the
appearance of a boil
rather than or of the bubo rather than
getting bitten by the flea yeah um as
kind of catching them did you catch the
bubonic plague
um
rejected 2003 because you know although
american exceptionalism was an important
part of it i didn't think it was a
primary part of it
and you know 2010 and the
failure to prioritize full employment
seems to me to be a good point in the
middle to balance
plus plus since 2010 we have we not only
no longer have american exceptionalism
that kind of god knows no one in china
thinks they have anything to learn from
the united states after trump today
um
and not only do we have slower
technological growth but yeah we do have
the inability of the world to even try
to
deal with
the new major he challenged the humanity
of the 21st century that of global
warming and it seems that around 2010
you know that the
that there still were a bunch of people
who were pretending that you know the
el nino year of 1998 was
you know um
an anomaly and that since 1998 there
really hadn't been any global warming um
yeah after 2010 even the page hills of
the oil companies
kind of dropped that argument
and so
the story of our increasing wealth and
our failure to build utopia on it seemed
to end
and
a time in which the history of the world
will be largely what happened what does
global warming do to us
um seem to me to begin
that's fair okay but to be you know to
be unfair
i will i know the time is running out so
i will ask you one last question
uh
what do we do about it
what is the right system you know how do
we fix all this uh how do we
pick up our pace of slouching toward
utopia given what we've learned
well you know i'm at
that bottom i'm still a
semi-unreconstructed social democrat you
know i think we should try that again
um and we should ride that again by you
know
um
saying that we're now rich enough that
you know um
people are generally inventive and
ingenious and are good at finding things
to do
and if for some number of people finding
those things to do does not involve
making much money
um well you know that really isn't a
problem we are a rich and an abundant
society
and you know so what if we have an awful
lot more artists
and coast players than in some sense we
need
they'll go on tick-tock and amuse some
people and the fact that there isn't a
major money flow associated with this
isn't a problem um
yeah that
the idea that people have to work hard
in socially um
appropriate and respected ways really
should be something we start trying to
banish from our mental universe
and so have a bunch of public stuff
you know and have a bunch of income
support problems
and you know recognize that
you know
mothers raising small children and
people taking care of their aunts and
uncles and so forth
are actually doing extremely valuable
social work for humanity you know um
that
in a good world we all would have baby
bones
that most of our wealth in fact indeed
all of our wealth
is due to things that none of us have
ever paid for right um
none of us pays royalties to the
descendants of ishbal who first decided
in a thousand bc
that you should use a stylized picture
of an ox to represent the phoneme
and that's an incredibly valuable thing
yeah um
you know james clerk maxwell and his
predecessors none of us are paying
royalties um to them
for understanding you know how it is
that
we actually can start to make electrons
dance
in a way that is up
i mean
look it's all fabulously extraordinary
um you know if you as a jumped up east
african plains age you know the idea
that there is that
rather than kind of tissues and things
you push and pull and can break that
underneath this there's this incredibly
complicated level of you know
microscopic balancing forces that are so
extraordinary powerful
that if only one thing goes slightly
wrong
now you know this horrible accident in
orinda california a decade ago
where two people in a um
in a bucket truck got within four feet
of one of the extremely high voltage
lines
right coming through
and you know they die
um four feet of air is insufficient
insulation
given how much energy is flowing
through it and flowing
totally invisibly without any signs of
effect
just because the normal electrical field
balance and the fact that of neutrality
and macroscopic has been
peeled away and the electrons are
shaking 60 times a second that's i mean
you know as elizabeth warren said it no
one became rich by themselves
um we all build on top of this enormous
structure of knowledge and we also all
rely on this enormous cooperative
division of labor
um by which you know the
you know adam smith says you know we
don't trust to the benevolence of the
butcher to sell us meat instead it's an
exchange of
money for meat but in some sense that's
wrong
that if the butcher were really
self-interested we come into the shop he
hits us over the head
butchers us and sells us as long pig
takes our money
we have an enormously productive and
new cooperative division of labor and we
should recognize that
um
however however
that's utopian
in an unsuccessful sense
people really really want
people to get what they deserve in both
good and bad senses
and we have to figure out a way in which
we can have a peaceful prosperous and
civilized and well-running society
given this enormous human belief which
has all kinds of bad
consequences you know one of which is
you know now going away twelve thousand
miles from now where vladimir putin has
convinced huge amounts of russians to
try to convince a lot of other people in
the world that they are not ukrainians
after all
but rather russians too
i don't know
right um
that is my
one of the ways i closed the book um
is to refer to john maynard keynes back
in 1924
when
things looked similarly
bleak you know that is the system that
had supported rapid economic growth
worldwide between 1870 and 1914 had
broken down in world war one and wasn't
being successfully built and you know
he was essentially said we need to think
harder
and
so i think i need to think harder
but one advantage of this is that now i
get to write a bunch of articles about
what ideas i can come up with for this
and i have not included in my book a
last chapter on what we need to do next
which last chapters are always
unconvincing in social science and they
always make the book stale
because a year after it's published
those last chapters are clearly and so
let me dodge your question let me say
have me on in a year to talk about my
articles
um because it's only by not answering
that what are we going to do next
question that i have a chance of
actually making my book not a kind of
ticket punching exercise
or something that's going to win
applause at the moment but actually a
useful treasure for all time
as an empirical fact
people who write a book and then say i'm
going to follow it up with some articles
always end up writing another book
yeah
so you might have another book in the
future that that will give us all the
solutions to these questions
there may well be several that would be
great okay
thanks so much for being on the
windscape podcast thank you this is an
extraordinary pleasure and let me thank
you very much again for doing this right
you've been doing this for quite a while
now
four years yeah yeah it's it's my way of
forcing myself to read all these books
it works
and you know it's been an
extraordinarily successful and value
thing valuable thing for you to do
and yet another way in which i feel kind
of one down in our parasocial gift
exchange relationship
we'll talk about eigen values of the
hamiltonian at some point then we'll
we'll even it up okay all right thanks
brad take care all right thank you very
much yep goodbye
[Music]
you